прошу тиші і якщо ви дослухаєтеся то
зараз ви почуєте звуки
похоронного маршу
це похорони децентралізації тої реформи
яку я разом з партнерами робив і зробив
з 14-го року
як принизливо зараз чути позицію що якщо
хочуть суб'єкти місцевого самоврядування
Нехай вони допомагають армії Але гроші
ми в них заберемо
це цинізм брехня і знущання над
конституцією це знущання на волонтерами
боресурсу волонтерів залишаються менше і
спільні заходи волонтерів і бригад
дозволяють звернутися до суб'єктів
місцевого самоврядування щодо коштів про
субвенції і термінової негайно вирішити
проблеми які виникають перед бригадами
Саме цей спонукало мене і нашу команду
підготувати альтернативний законопроект
в альтернативному законопроекті 100%
коштів які знаходять від субвенції
можуть бути витрачені виключно на
завдання оборони
жодної позиції по бруківкам А вашірезкам
І все таке інше
готуються Ці пропозиції виключно на базі
пропозиції бригад які мають пункт
постійної дислокації
використовуються ці кошти також для
цивільного захисту для бомбосховищ для
багатьох інших речей Я закликаю
депутатів мажоритарників ті хто працюють
з волонтерами ті хто тут вишукався з
прапорами бригад дати відсіч цьому
законопроекту підтримати мій
законопроект захистити
військовослужбовців і перемогти
перемогти Путіна а не на виборах це є
наше завдання Дякую Слава Україні